etes-vous la chanteuse préférée de
michel fugain
michel fugain fait partie de mes
chanteurs préférés mais quoi non mais
c'est vous qui le dites je sais pas qui
c'est en audience et du cube vendu que
[Rires]
tu es jeune maman et c'est une jeune
maman le bébé les jeunes mamans vous
l'aimez bien le chantier là dedans
nolwenn nicolas vous connaissez mal web
oui je crois vous l'aimez bien ça va oui
bon toi j'écoute que ça bon ben
alors non loin des faits concernant le
pas à chaque fois pour seulement de ton
avis ça serait rien si tu fais un tour
de table et quand enfin tour de taille
et qui n'est pas dans le tour de table
aïe ça c'est ça ça ne m'énerve qu'est ce
que tu penses de nolwenn leroy j'aime
pas du tout même parti je n'aime pas la
femme ouais et je trouve qu'elles sont
de la bouche franchement
non on se connaît depuis longtemps c'est
pour ça que je pense
parce que j'adore nolwenn ah oui c'est
vrai
thierry oui est ce que vous allez vous
entêtez toute l'émission a appelé
isabelle adjani nolwenn leroy
et pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
dinars 10 tubes abonnez vous je m'étais
un peu ce bleu